commodity prices around the world are
absolutely spiking this is insane it's
not something that we've seen since the
financial recession of 2020. now of
course when we first start with wheat we
haven't seen wheat prices this high ever
what we're watching is that wheat
futures have hit an all-time high
surpassing the prior high from 2008
according to charlie bolillo prices have
now increased 75 since the start of the
year russia is the world's largest
exporter of wheat and ukraine is the
fifth largest exporter of the same
commodity but it's not just wheat that
we're looking at if we go ahead and we
take a look at nickel nickel is
exploding as well it's literally trading
like a [ __ ] coin the london metal
exchange has halted trading a nickel
because it went up
250 percent and it left brokers
struggling to pay margin calls many of
the top producers can't meet those
margin calls and so there's a lot of
instability and chaos going on in the
nickel market right now that isn't
exactly a normal chart in any asset in
financial markets and then of course if
we go and we take a look at oil oil is
the number one commodity to pay
attention to right now russia is the
third largest producer of oil they're
the 17 percent of all natural gas
produced in the world and those russian
prices continue to rocket upwards as the
united states is now thinking about
banning all imports of russian crude and
so of course whether we are talking
about wheat or oil or nickel commodity
prices are correlating towards one
prices are exploding upwards and people
around the world are wondering what is
the impact of all of this but if we go
back and we look at history history is a
god it doesn't necessarily repeat always
but as a guide we can see a recession
could be near sven henrich pointing out
that the last time wheat prices were
this high the global financial crisis
ensued and of course if we look at
something like oil chamoth palopatia
recently stated that when oil prices
spike 50 or more every single time in
the last 30 to 40 years a recession has
ensued he then went on to tweet this
where he said history repeats itself in
2018 the fed was concerned about
inflation they were wrong and within a
quarter or so the risk shifted to
recession this chart shows how the
equity markets reacted and it seems
eerily similar now of course nobody has
a crystal ball nobody knows what is
going to happen but what we do know is
that commodity prices are exploding
upwards and a recession is looming the
federal reserve is in a lose-lose
situation do nothing and inflation will
continue to ravage hundreds of millions
of people around the world act and raise
interest rates and you're likely to
accelerate us moving into a recessionary
period lose lose tails you lose heads
you lose inflation or recession you pick
your poison we're not in a good
situation these commodity prices are a
huge warning sign i don't envy being
somebody sitting at the federal reserve
having to make these decisions but what
you at home need to do is understand
what's happening and how you can protect
yourself hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time